now is it true that you were
in contention and whenever i hear this i
know what that
we all know what that's like it means it
may be true maybe it isn't for titanic
so i went red for titanic with kate
winslet
and it was not one of the auditions it
was like they filmed it
so it was like into screen test time
and i left there did jim shoot it hand
held did jim shoot it himself cameron
he had to do it right i think so i don't
remember though
he did jim i think because i only got
like
nods from jim but from the producers and
kate and everything we like
after we left you know it was one of
those ones where they like followed me
and on when we got outside they were
like that went great i mean
kind of like hugs i really thought it
was going to happen
okay did not so did not now
i still because because i've i asked i
asked
um cameron about this because the the
the sort of gossip over years that i had
heard and would see written about me was
that i had the role of titanic and
turned it down
not not factual i did not get offered
that role
because i've always said i was like for
a while i was saying like who was my i
got to find that agent
they're in trouble no way if i got that
well i did never get the offer
i did not ever get the offer um and jim
finally confirmed that but he either got
someone
he either malaprop something or someone
took something he said and that ran for
a while and i had to answer that
question
i never got offered that as far as i
know i'm telling you i did go have a
good screen test thought i had the role
but did not get the role
so yeah i was in contention i it could
have been a different movie you could
have been that and i could i was uh
i screen tested for the billy zane bad
guy part
with okay and jim shot that i'll never
forget he shot hand-held shot at himself
okay neither one of us neither one of us
made the cut
but we were in the running we were in
the running would it be yeah we were we
could have been contenders buddy